what's happening with you and Devin
Booker
um he's my boyfriend well that's not the
case anymore because the source tells
E.T Kendall Jenner and Devin Booker have
called it quits for the second time this
year oh my God just be cool yeah these
two first-ended things in June before
quickly reconciling but cut to October
and they decided to go their separate
ways again as for why well our source
says quote they are both still young and
extremely busy in their careers it was
becoming difficult for them to
prioritize their relationship with their
schedules and with that said there are
no hard feelings the decision was Mutual
they still care about each other they
are both enjoying single life staying
busy and spending time with loved ones I
think that it's kind of as simple as
that this both is and isn't a shock
seeing as the couple mostly kept their
romance under the radar it was rare to
see them out and about together though
they were looking in love just a month
before the split packing on the PDA at
the U.S open at the time the source
close to the model told E.T Kendall was
starting to feel more comfortable with
PDA and they'd never see seen Kendall
like this our source added that Kenny
always had love for Devin even when they
were separated but was more into him
than ever before after they got back
together so there are still some holes
here ones will probably never get filled
in you know we learn and again our
boundaries may change one day depending
on the situation yeah one boundary
candles kept clear for years her private
life is just that I like to keep my
private life pretty private so I try my
best but at the same time I don't I
don't like to let being seen out in
public with someone like affect my
everyday life the reality star and NBA
player were first Linked In The Summer
of 2020. I think it makes my life a lot
easier in our relationship a lot better
to be completely honest I just feel like
it's a private matter it's not really
for anybody else to to judge or no but
it wasn't until a year later that
Kendall confirmed Devin was her man it's
not always easy as for how Kendall and
Devin will move forward in each other's
lives well another source tells E.T they
want to remain supportive even though
they're no longer a couple they had a
lot of love for each other and connected
over many things including loving the
Wilderness and being down to earth Devon
is a gentleman and has always made sure
to treat Kendall with respect he plans
to continue doing that
[Music]